spider-man is the biggest Marvel
character he is the jewel in the crown
such an amazing icon he is a very
different type of hero because he is
quite simply the greatest superhero of
all time
everybody is Charlie we got a whole
bunch of new spider-man to talk about
today as Kevin Feige said world's best
superhero everybody wants a piece of him
turns out he's supposed to appear during
the Kraven the hunter movie so I'll
explain what's going on because it does
sound a little bit confusing when you
hear like wait a minute spider-man
versus Kraven what about all the stuff
that Marvel is doing if you're new to
the channel there's a new brown of that
spider-man ps4 game giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video what
happened was is that during New York
Comic Con there were a whole bunch of
interviews everybody talking about their
projects people were talking to the
screenwriter that's working on Sony's
Craven movie that's supposed to be
inside their spider-verse
very surprisingly he was extremely
forthcoming about what his movie was
going to be they don't have a director
on it right now they're just working on
developing the project so who knows when
that's going to come out presumably some
time after the Morbius movie because
Morbius is gonna start shooting in
February next year but Kraven is just
like the latest really huge character
that Sony has said they're gonna turn
into a big film they have a whole bunch
of those other smaller films but I don't
think some of those are gonna see the
light of day they just announced a whole
bunch of projects there's a lot of
people to think that Sony might try to
sell their film studio to somebody else
and in order to do that they're putting
a bunch of spider-man movies into
development to make it seem like the
studio has more value like look at all
these amazing spider-man movies that are
gonna make all this money don't you want
to buy our studio so those billions of
dollars could be yours we'll check back
in on that year to year depending on how
all these films end up going but the
whole deal is is that Richard wank is
the name of the screenwriter this making
this Kraven the hunter movie
he says the screenplay is going to
adhere very closely to the law of Kraven
the hunter not really a big surprise
there of course everybody wants to make
it as comic book accurate as possible
when asked to be very specific about
which comic book storylines he was going
to adapt though he said he plans to pull
from all cravin spider-man comics but
particularly they're circling
Craven's last hunt probably the most
iconic comic book Cravens story no
surprise there unlike spider-man he
doesn't have a billion really awesome
comic book stories to pull from just a
couple one of the other ones was the
creation of the sinister six he was a
founding member of that team they were
starting to set that out during Andrew
Garfield era I'll play that post-credit
scene in a second but that's about as
close as we've ever gotten to Kraven the
hunter in the live-action movies so part
of the reason why I think we haven't
seen him before is is because especially
like in the early 2000s when we're
getting Tobey Maguire and some of those
characters they just felt like those
toys wouldn't sell quite as well in a
lot of the way those movies were
envisioned especially through Andrew
Garfield were that they were trying to
pick the most bankable villain and if
you don't do it right Craven just winds
up being a weirdo but now that we've
gotten to the point where you have a
talking raccoon in a talking tree weird
is the new bankable so people aren't as
afraid to try really weird stuff grew
put that thing away
now I don't want to tell you again hey
got some acorns on you kid ever since
you got a little SAP you're a total deal
we've all heard about how early on the
Black Panther movie was going to feature
Kraven the hunter instead of the kill
monger character I think they made the
right choice but the whole idea was is
Kevin Feige said with these new Spider
Man films since that they were using
villains they had not used before that's
why we're getting Mysterio during
spider-man far from home the Craven
screenwriter said obviously it's going
to be an origin story they might split
it into two films he really wants them
to get Antoine Fuqua but I don't know
how much power the actual screenwriter
has and choosing the director so Sony is
gonna pick whoever they want to pick but
the reason why people are reporting this
spider-man is going to appear during the
film is because he says the movie is
going to bring Kraven face-to-face with
spider-man so as you can imagine a
couple people just had whip-crack
reactions like wait what what do you
think spider-man he wasn't even in the
venom movie how are you gonna get him in
that Kraven the hunter movie there are
only a couple ways something like that
could legit end up happening because
Sony definitely does want to get Tom
Holland in there spider-verse
to make it even more legit regardless of
how you feel about the venom movie a lot
of people are saying that Tom Holland
has accidentally let slip that they are
working on a third spider-man film at
Marvel Studios with Sony which means
that they would have to extend their
sharing arranged
even longer say like another two years
after next summer so that's through 2021
in Kevin Feige really doesn't want to
have anything to do with that Sony
spider-verse remember you know famous
interview with Amy Pascal where he just
kind of sits there triggered quietly
trying not to say anything when she's
like yeah phantom is totally connected
to the MCU
well those movies will all take place in
the world that we are now creating for
for you know for Peter Parker I mean
it'll they'll be adjuncts to it they may
be different locations but it will still
all be in the same world and they will
be connected to each other as well such
an instant classic he said he totally
appreciated being turned into a meme
during interviews after that like oh
yeah that was fun but he's not a big
social media person so you won't catch
him tweeting that often if they really
have re-signed that sharing arrangement
I would be willing to bet that there are
some stipulations about how they can use
spider-man lore inside their
spider-verse with all the venom movies
and these other spin-offs and it
probably does not include appearances
from Tom Holland but if you've ever
watched any comic book TV show that's
based on movie lore there are always
alias characters that are never allowed
to appear on certain TV shows both
Marvel and DC so like think about the
way the Marvel Netflix shows address and
reference stuff that's happening in the
movies it might wind up being a scenario
like that or say like on the DC TV shows
when they want to use Superman Batman
Wonder Woman stuff they'll have them in
shadows off screen they'll reference
them in pictures there's ways for
including those characters that don't
necessarily include them just walking on
frame and waving hello and interacting
with whatever's going on in the plot I
also kind of think the writer of this
movie is doing his version of Cravens
last hunt and he'll put spider-man in it
then by the time they get to later
drafts Sony will note him to death
saying that no sorry up the food chain
they say no spider-man you got to take
him out of the script so right now as we
speak there might be a version of this
movie with spider-man in it but I
definitely don't think that's the
version we're going to be watching when
it eventually makes it to the big screen
if you've never read Cravens last hunt
it was actually a story they've
collected it since then but it took
place across a bunch of spider-man
titles and it was basically an older
version of Kraven that had just become
so disillusioned with his inability to
catch spider-man that he really went for
it wanted to prove that he could be
better than spider-man so he catches him
knocks him out for a couple days buries
him in the ground so that people think
that he's dead
assumes his identity wearing a replica
spider-man costume goes after a villain
called vermin that's been terrorizing
the city that spider-man by himself was
never able to take down Kraven kicks his
ass so he feels like he's achieved
victory but he's crazy brutal so it's
like if the Punisher became spider-man
like that's not really what spider-man
is supposed to be like he's not really
capturing the essence of that character
while this is happening the serum that
he injected into spider-man wears off he
comes back to consciousness pounds his
way out of the ground in the grave Kill
Bill style then goes after Kraven but
because Kraven has achieved what he
views as his victory like I've become a
better version of you
he doesn't resist spider-man then
eventually goes back to his home and
kills himself because he feels like he's
achieved his greatest victory I've done
everything that I can do so now it's
over now he didn't stay dead for a long
time because his children who had taken
up his mantle brought him back to life
using the blood of spider-man and some
special rituals would probably wind up
happening is is that will here in
another year or two that they've tried
to substitute Tom Hardy's venom for
spider-man during that last hunt
storyline but we haven't really heard
about when they're rolling into
production on the venom verse carnage
movie post all your reactions in the
comments below though I do love how
popular spider-man is right now remember
we have spider-man into the spider verse
coming in December there'll be more
footage for that soon if you do have
special spider-man video requests you
want me to do just let me know in the
comments below I'm gonna leave the
spider-man giveaway open for the next
couple of videos so I'll just remind
people when I post new Marvel but
there's some new flash footage that I'll
probably do later tonight click here to
watch Chris Evans talk all about
Avengers 4 and click here for that
spider-man far from home red black new
costume video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
guys tonight
[Music]
you